all right kathy hi kathy uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
was born in charleston west virginia but
i'm born and raised in red house
and now you're living in nitro yes moved
up city life
tell me about your childhood how did you
grow up i was adopted
pretty much got everything i wanted my
parents made sure all my bills were
always paid they were really concerned
about anything i had a bunch of kids six
six kids five boys one girl so you got
adopted into a good family yes i had we
had one adopted brother but um
he chased me through the house with a
loaded shotgun before i'm younger and uh
hit me one time when he was like 14
black both my eyes were swollen shut
and he was kind of really mean to me
and uh but your childhood was how would
you describe your childhood oh perfect
and
perfect and then um lost my dad then i
lost my mom and like i said
what age
it was in 2005
she passed away and got a bunch of money
from that and kind of blew it
never having it before it went crazy
uh bought a house
my mom right before she passed away
said she had a dream that me and my
brother never spoke to each other again
it really hurt her and
kind of what happened
it is what it is though
after she died
i never saw any of my family anymore
they
kind of cut me and my children out
and um
i think jamison said you got the power
back on yeah we
learned how to do things like that
excuse me
legally and
uh unlegally guess i've kind of taught
my crew how to
to survive it
if it ever does happen you know know how
to get by would use the generator for a
long time and i still live without
running water
was that right
yeah
it's difficult but it's possible
um
[Music]
where do you eat water from
rain
really yes yes right we do have a well
out back but we don't use it
not sure what what it would be so you
collect the rain water and
use that to
clean house do dishes take a bath
i go somewhere else to wash clothes
though yeah i've heard that a lot same
thing with electricity a lot of people
are just generator or candle and i was
telling james that
honestly those were some of the best
times we ever had as a family there's
one family
two brothers whose mom just passed away
who
not too far from here
who had one light bulb
for the whole house and they would go
from room to room
unscrew the light bulb and plug it in
you know screw it into that i can i can
relate with that yeah i can relate with
that west virginia is a very different
and
parts of kentucky are very very
different from the rest of the country
you learn you learn to survive it's that
song a country boy will survive
that that's true
so you made it through school high
school oh yeah i graduated i had my
first son
um i was 18 and his dad had just turned
16. he was 15 when i got pregnant i was
17 when i got pregnant
how many kids do you have six six yeah
after that i went to florida a few times
with my best friend
um
quite a few times back and forth
uh we had a lot of
a lot of fun doing that
i had a few more kids in between all
those times
i
had my daughter and i actually had
surgery not to have any more kids four
years later i had another child
that was when i got arrested
and caught the felony i was telling you
about earlier what was that for um
i lived in the town of poca and i lived
within 1 000 feet of polka middle school
and i sold
2 grams of weed to a guy
two times
and it made it two felonies i was i was
the first person in west virginia
prosecuted under that law
and it was a mandatory five-year
sentence but
that ain't always true the judge decides
your sentence i got two and a half years
of probation
okay which i did real well on so you did
some time or you didn't i did a little
bit of time in jail and then you got
yeah yeah and i was the only person in
rehab for weed too
surprise surprise because the judge said
normally they don't do that for weed
because you don't have any symptoms like
other people on drugs i've tried a lot
of different drugs but never
bought them but drugs are not really
part of your life
with my children they are yeah but with
you they're not no they're not a problem
for me no yeah but this this area
it's so rapid i've watched my children
literally
disappear they're not the same people
they were i'll see
yeah
yeah that's it's really sad it's
i couldn't tell you how many people i
know that have died
that between the ages of 20 and 30
you know it's
it's rampant it really is there's
what drugs are they playing around with
heroin and i guess it's ice now it used
to be meth but they don't make meth
anymore
they could all get shipped in from out
of state
so
what do you think the reason is that so
many
especially the younger people
the younger generation are addicted to
drugs here
i cannot say it was boredom because like
i said while ago we grew up bored and
didn't have that problem i don't
but you also didn't have it available to
you back then right well they did
quaaludes back in the day
they quit making those but i i never did
qualities but i know a lot of people are
very very oh yeah yeah cocaine was a big
thing back in them days as well
but maybe it is because it is so easily
available
and but it's such a beautiful part of
the country one of the most beautiful
parts of the country
yes it is and
yet
so many of the younger generation are
addicted to drugs they don't even get
out to see it what percentage just
guests you know just
high school high school-wise or young
adult young adult wise i would say close
to 80 85
yeah that's what it seems like yeah i
guarantee
of my son trying to find a girlfriend i
said you're not going to find one around
here that's not got a problem
and same vice versa you know good luck
it's just
and a couple on drugs is never going to
last it's not going to work out so
no in the future for this region
is bleak because oh really yes
definitely like none of these people are
addicted to heroin or
things are shutting down since the
kovoid thing everything's shutting down
even more
so it's just we were talking about
golden corral it's nothing now just
sitting down there empty
yeah it's
yeah
but um
my oldest son i've been estranged from
him for probably three years he was on
drugs
and he was quite a bully so
he had to leave and i haven't allowed
him to come back and until they till
they stop what
they're doing i can't
allow it what was he doing it was so he
was doing a lot of math he used to work
at a strip bar in huntington
i think they eventually closed down due
to covoid as well
he had some family that he could go stay
with
what's your biggest regret in your life
the biggest one i have a lot
what are some of your regrets
i guess i wish that i would have stayed
with my dad when he was passing away
instead of coming back home
i wish i would have stayed with my mom
i wish i would have went with my best
friend
to her home to get the suitcases before
when she got shot her her husband shot
her and killed her we were getting she
just got a big settlement from
mountaineer gas we will take my kids to
disney world and
she was running home get the suitcases
and never came back and
like this was on good friday easter
sunday her dad called and said it wasn't
good news
he had shot her shot himself and
the fish tank
and i wish i would have maybe if i would
have went
she would have still been here
it was two months after that she died
that i lost my mom
so i kind of lost my best friend and my
mom and my family all at once
a lot of tragedy in your life a lot of
tragedy in this in this area yeah but
like i said i have we have good times
too
was the best time your life
probably going to florida with my friend
it takes money to stay down there though
you can't
i didn't have nothing here holding me
back except financial
financial means she had three kids and
her daughter just bought a house in
south beach miami
me and my daughter's gonna go down there
and visit her
soon but
i miss her a lot yeah
what is your hope for your future
for you and your family
we go day to day
i hope every day we get to eat
if it's cold outside stay warm if it's
hot outside stay cool
yeah it's day to day thing yeah you
can't can't really plan a whole lot
what emotions do you go through do you
deal with
i'm in a lot of pain from my leg
depression from my friends
watching my kids just
you know when they're my age they're not
gonna have anything to talk about what
you know what did they do
you're sitting back in the bedroom
getting high it's not
going to be a memory that you're going
to want to share with people when you
get older
is this the roughest time in your life
right now yes
yes
like i said after growing up having my
parents pay all my bills for me
yeah you came from almost a charmed
childhood right right and i wasn't
taught how to
to do it for myself so i always depended
on them so it was a big shock at 30
something years old to be like oh shoot
you know they're cutting off the
electric used to call my mom up and she
would just pay it for me
and i had to do it on my own
so of your six kids you had
are
uh
six kids with the same father i have six
kids with five different fathers
but you've been in love before
once but he was not a father of any of
my children
right
right
um
yeah i was actually telling my daughter
i said when i go buy the father's day
cards i got to have at least a buck 25
for the dollar store to get everybody a
card
but they're all
super nice you know we could still get i
could call them up and ask them for
something if i needed it you guys get
along yeah and they all get along with
each other my son even said one time and
they're weird that all of our dads even
get along and
thank god that they do
yeah are you worried about
um
a roof over my head i guess
keeping a roof over my head it's
survival at this point right yeah
yeah day to day i was getting
unemployment
and it was cut off in june so basically
i'm just living on what jonah gives me
as rent i make them pay 50 a week and i
have another son that lives with me with
his girlfriend
they're supposed to give me 50 a week
supposed to
so
i live off of that
when i worked at the dairy queen um
i see people talking all the time
they live in poverty at 20 grand a year
i made four thousand dollars that year
and i thought we did pretty good i mean
we ate every day we had electricity then
and probably running water
but yeah we made it on four grand a year
some people bring that home in a month
dear friends
i've had a lot of friends i have a few
close friends now my friends have all
died
and that's that's the saddest thing i
mean
[Music]
people aren't like what they used to be
really
you know it's
yeah it seems like the older generation
seems to be so
um
god-fearing and and knew what trust and
loyalty was yeah it really did
and nowadays and yeah
i might know you for six months and
still not trust you
i wouldn't trust my kids with the twenty
dollars to go to the end of sidewalk for
me and there's
what do you think the answer might be
for this part of the country
i have no idea it's
it's not technology
i don't think that's the answer
it doesn't seem to have helped anywhere
could it be jobs yeah schooling maybe
coal mining is kind of dried up yeah
other industries have
left
kids need schooling learn learn the
fundamentals
grow in their own food
my grandma had a farm and i loved that
i loved going out on the farm
yeah
yeah the way the kids grow up now is is
very very different than the way you
grew up oh definitely definitely they
don't know what they were missing
they do have some perks but
like you said not the family stuff we
ate sunday dinner at my grandma's you
know
the chicken that they fried they got out
of the backyard
the well the water came from the well
right off the back porch and it tasted
so good
it's just
crazy yeah it's amazing how life has
changed over one generation
it sure has
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
not to count on anyone
not to count on anyone
you gotta find it in yourself to do it
for yourself
i didn't know i would cry so much that's
okay
well kathy thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you for having me here
she's telling me you know you don't do
drugs at all and i said but he hangs out
with all these shady people
you've got to be kidding me no i don't
but
i can relate to everyone's story